well if you want to understand leftism
in the Modern Age and by extension our
culture you need to First understand
what I call the victim
hierarchy if you understand the victim
hierarchy you understand everything and
uh and so you need to understand how it
works so we're going to run through it
today this kind of tutorial which will
tell you everything you need to know
about uh leftism and about our culture
by extension now the victim hierarchy is
a pyramid you could also call it the
victim pyramid VH or VP it's to you at
the base of the pyramid you have white
men that's the lowest ranking they
cannot be victimized by anyone and yet
they victimize everyone else we have to
understand is that victimization flows
up on the pyramid so it's a little
counterintuitive higher you are on the
pyramid the more victimized you are and
yet the more powerful you
are now next you have white women which
and they're still pretty low on the
ranking but they can at least be
victimized by white men so they have one
victim Point victim points are
determined by how many other groups can
victimize you so you can tally a group's
victim points simply by counting how
many groups are underneath them on the
pyramid it makes it very easy to do now
flowing up from there uh right above
white women we have disabled people now
this is a large category and uh it's in
fact getting larger by the day because
what counts as disability keeps
expanding by the day but of course you
know there are just like the classic
disabilities we all recognize blind deaf
wheelchair bound Etc and these are going
to kind of Be the Anchor points for the
disabled category of the victim pyramid
now these people are group three and so
they are automatically victimized by the
two groups below them which gives them
two victim points next and this gets a
little confusing uh we have fat people
the obese sometimes obesity is counted
as a disability sometimes it isn't but
the group is large enough no pun
intended that it needs its own category
and the plus-size Community has been
sort of climbing the hierarchy in recent
years which has been really good
exercise for them now the obese have
three categories is below them which
means that they have three victim points
now we get to the part where the rubber
meets the road what is called our
premium victim categories
PVC now at this stage every victim point
is multiplied by two there is a times
two bonus for getting to this point on
the victim pyramid I'll show you how it
works the first group in the premium
category are black men who now for the
purpose of this demonstration in order
to keep things as simple as possible
black will include all racial minorities
of course in reality there's a separate
victim ranking of racial minorities that
tends to change rapidly over time as
different groups VI for greater victim
status for right now we're all going to
include them uh as under the black
category or we could just say people of
color now black men therefore have four
victim points times the premium victim
bonus which makes eight points what's
next obviously next would be black women
who are victimized by black men fat
people disabled people white women and
white men those are all of the
victimization flows up through those
groups and black women are uh are are
getting all of that and this gives them
a gross of five victim points but a net
of 10 when you add the premium victim
bonus gays lesbians and other non-hetero
sexual orientations fall just above
black women they are victimized by an
impressive tally of six other groups and
then our premium victim bonus kicks in
and what you get you get 12 victim
points and that is where the LGB land on
the pyramid but of course I have not
mentioned the T oh hey girl get over
here let's talk some that's because the
te sits at the top the very top of the
pyramid nobody can out victim the tea
the victims who are the victims of all
other victims they stand at the Pinnacle
of the victim hierarchy which means that
they are the most victimized which means
that that they have the most victim
points and therefore the most power and
here we introduce what is called the
Apex victim multiplier
AVM whatever group sits at the top the
Apex victim earns their seven victim
points but then they also earn a
multiple of 10 which means that trans
people have not seven or even 14 victim
points but they have 70 well no one's
going to top that here's where things
get tricky what about the crossover in
groups a fat woman is below a black
woman on the hierarchy but what about a
fat black woman where does she rank how
do we make sense of a gay black fat deaf
man in a wheelchair is he above black
women on the pyr or is he still below
can a white woman Leap Frog over black
men and black women if she's also a
member of some these other categories is
there anything that a white man like
myself can do to get out from the bottom
of this whole heap how do we sort
through this it seems sort of
overwhelming well don't worry it's not
as difficult as it seems at first
following the intersectional victim
calculus IVC all you have to do is add
the total points of every group a person
belongs to so let's do the math let's
say that a white woman very low ranking
member of the victim hierarchy is also
disabled and fat and bisexual well now
she has her one victim point plus two
for disabled three for fat and 12 for
bisexual now she has 18 total victim
points which puts her comfortably above
a normal non-gay non-fat non-disabled
black man or woman now there's one
important note here you cannot cash in
multiple times in the disabled category
what so if you are blind and also in a
wheelchair that's only two victim points
those are the rules I'm not saying I
agree with them it's just how it goes
forgive me master you may have noticed
that because of the Apex victim
multiplier no non-trans person can get
anywhere close to the trans victim Point
Talent trans will always remain the top
victim which means that even that that
that lowly white man all the way at the
bottom with his zero victim points even
he can easily rock it all the way to the
top just by coming out as trans a black
man who has done a lot of work to become
fat and gay and everything else who has
secured a position in four or five other
categories will still have to bow before
the white man as the top victim if he
the white man simply identifies as a
woman now let's say the black man comes
out as a as a woman well then he once
again is going to be above the white man
in the trans tier although trans is at
the top that category is itself
subdivided depending on the race weight
disability status Etc of any individual
transperson this does get confusing
though because the trans victim
subdivisions follow the same logic as
the overall victim pyramid except that
trans women who are actually male slide
in above trans men who are actually
female on the broader pyramid being
female buys you points right but once
you make it into the top Echelon the
trans tier being female makes you male
which subtracts your points so a black
woman who comes out as trans will now be
below a black man who comes out as trans
as the sexist have switched what this
means is that if you want to build the
Uber ultimate unbeatable victim the
emperor of the whole victim pyramid you
need to start with a black man that's
going to be the best canvas upon which
you can paint the ultimate victim with
that building block you can assemble a
victim who is more victimized than any
other victim so if you are therefore a
straight black man of average weight and
physical capability you may only have a
few victim points but if you dream big
enough and put in the work you could be
the greatest victim of all remember I
didn't make these rules I'm only here to
tell you what they are and well there
they
are